how are you I'm 26. 26. you're very
young
dominatrix I am yeah how did you first
get introduced to this
um I've always been like really
interested in the psychology of it and I
have this really good friend who's like
a really really talented and experienced
Dominatrix and she
would have me come and help her
sometimes
um and I really like kind of felt like I
found my calling doing it and I felt
really comfortable and kind of in my
element something that I hadn't felt
before so I decided to pursue it like on
my own as well so you feel like it's in
your nature
I do and I feel like
it's really helped me like kind of
almost heal from a lot of trauma that
I've had as well like regarding men and
and taking being taken advantage of I
feel like sort of
spun it to where I'm taking my power
back and and really kind of healing in
my own way